spotify in the last 12 months
they've lost 25 percent of its value
okay in the last 12 months uh
spotify stock has lost can you go to
that okay right there spotify stock has
lost nearly 25 percent of its value in
and 40 i was wrong 45 percent over the
past 20 uh year what's going on so
what's the date you see right there from
20 january 21 to today
it went from being 240 250 a share to
now being what 190
a share 184 a share as of can you go to
what it is today just go to what the
stock is today so we can find out and
during this time
uh uh can we find out when they signed
joe rogan put down when they signed joe
rogan spotify signed joe rogan what was
it may of 2020 i want to say so it's
been a year and a half 2020 june of 2020
because december 7th was when he was
leaving youtube something like that when
he said he's leaving youtube what's the
date may 2020 you're right okay may of
2020 they sound good memory i'm very
proud of that memory of yours so so then
here's what happens joe
responds yesterday did you see what you
did and i'm assuming you also saw what
he said i just watched it as i was
coming yeah you were commenting on it so
let me kind of read a few of these
things on what's going on and then we'll
get into it so
spotify
joe rogan and spotify um let's see if
it's this one yep joe rogan and spotify
uh spotify removes neil young's music
over rogan's dispute this is an nbc news
story spotify said it has agreed to
remove neil young's music after the
famed single writer said he wouldn't
share the platform with podcaster joe
rogan who has been criticized for
spreading vaccine disinformation they
can have rogan or young not both young
76 said the heart of gold singers solo
catalogue spanned more than five decades
from his 1969 self-titled album to his
most recent record 2021 barn
young called out the rogan experience in
his letter and they
the danger of spotify enabling the
distribution of potentially fatal
misinformation with an estimated 11
million listeners per episode jre which
is hosted exclusively on spotify has
tremendous influence spotify's
responsibility to mitigate
the spread of misinformation on its
platform and then harry and meghan
markle decided to comment as well they
are spotify to stop kobe 19
misinformation from spreading on this
platform this is an insider story a
spokesperson uh for arch archwell harry
and megan's foundation said in a
statement sunday last april our
co-founders began expressing concerns to
our partners on at spotify about the all
too real consequences of covenanting
misinformation on its platform spotify
shares dropped 12 follow neil young's
request and remove the music from the
platform harry and megan comments
followed the decision by young and joni
mitchell to request their songs be taken
off the platform in some cases a podcast
host saying they won't release new
episodes now by the way here's other
names that have come up william nelson
bruce springsteen which i think he sold
his catalog to sony for half a billion
dollars i don't even know if he can say
that sony decides whether they want to
take it off i think barbara streisand
queen paul mccartney rolling stones
david grove joni mitchell pearl jam are
removing their music wood spot from
spotify and solidarity
solidarity and keep in mind that 30
of all the buys of music is on spotify
so if people want to buy a song by snoop
30 of it is bought on spotify so it's
not like it's a small amount of people
can keep the fascists well let's let's
just there's no there's no
there's no proof to this comment right
here these artists there's 100 proof to
neil young and johnny if you go i don't
know if this is true no no no no go type
in bruce springsteen spotify if you if
you type in bruce springsteen and
spotify that's all you got to do that's
what i did yesterday
type in bruce springsteen and spotify
okay right there
it's an nbc story
right there's a guitar it's not him yeah
so so okay so these stories are coming
out what are your thoughts on this uh
james i've got
i've got
many thought i mean
it goes back to i'm sorry to get
philosophical again but it goes back to
this concept about what is
misinformation because i i watched the
rogan reaction on instagram as i was
driving to your studio this morning i
i'm glad i did and he and he said this
anecdotally said well things a year ago
or six months ago with the cloth mask
and you would be banned if you said it
well now it comes out as true from the
experts so it goes back to this
definition of
why are they why are they censoring why
they want him off because of
misinformation what does that even mean
and what it means is it goes back to
in from the authorized experts say
business so the the government the cdc
the experts the pharmaceutical companies
it goes back to what the experts say but
who are these experts
and and it goes back to the very idea of
what we're talking about this whole this
two-hour segment which is the
unauthorized information
it's our world is becoming such
you are only allowed to think and say
what the authorized knowers
and the presumed credible sources
permit you to say which is so
it's so
anathema to
what
journalism and the media is supposed to
be and rogan said he said you couldn't
even say these things a year ago that
now you're allowed to say you know i'm
going to tell a dirty joke not too dirty
though and by the way i'm happy to say
this publicly and privately you're i'm
um i'm in my um
i'm not married but let's for this joke
let's say that i am and uh i'm i'm in my
bedroom and i'm having an affair with
this beautiful woman and one night
this woman comes into my bedroom and she
goes oh my god how could you do this you
how could you do this you were been
married for 10 years
and and she's looking at me having this
affair and the next morning and she said
how could you do that to me and i said
well honey um that's actually been
debunked by experts familiar with the
matter experts say
that that you never saw that happen
right
so my question is disinformation this is
a rhetorical question disinformation is
based upon
experts and credible sources
um
and that's the problem with with our
modern ecosystem is that
you can't say anything contrary to what
those experts tell you
what do you think is going to happen
with spotify and joe long term like
do you see is there any chance that
spotify is going to make a big decision
danny elec is
do you see anything happening there the
only thing that they've come out and
said was that they're going to add
content advisories
to basically joe rogan's podcast did you
hear what he said had to say yesterday
daniel ackee came in and made
announcement he says listen i don't
agree with plenty of individuals on
spotify okay some i strongly disagree
with
we know we have a critical role to play
in supporting creator expression while
balancing it with the safety of our
users quote unquote we don't want to
play content censor but we are putting
rules in place well this is section 230
this is a central issue here this is the
white house quote you shouldn't be
banned from one platform and not another
so these companies can't have it both
ways they can either be platforms or
they can be
sort of they can make editorial
judgments
um and once these start what i saw
daniel eckers name
once you start making decisions to ban
certain things not others and you start
crossing that threshold now you're
effectively a news you're effectively uh
you're not protected by those immunities
and and and you should be sued for
liability these are tough issues and
we've never crossed this rubicon before
this is a this is a today here sitting
here today we've never gone this far so
i don't know what the future holds but
i don't know it could all and the other
thing is these ceos of these companies
these for-profit people like ek i don't
know what his values are but if your
value is money and profit
um they're kind what ends up happening
is they're always going to fold they're
not going to be able to stand firm
that's what i think is going to happen
they're going to fold and there's going
to be more censorship and i i think it's
bigger than just daniel eck look at look
at
twitter and uh jack dorsey
you know people have their thoughts on
jack dorsey but but people who know jack
say that the whole reason he started
twitter was for a free speech ecosystem
and he got pushed out by the board by
executives etc etc so now there's talk
of him starting his own platform but
what happens with spotify can can daniel
eck hold strong or will the executives
come in the board members come in and
say no we're done with you thank you
very much that's a that's a great
question because listen 45 you know how
much is 45
you're not talking they lost 16 million
dollars you're not talking they lost 100
million dollars or 400 million dollars
you're talking about
billions of dollars okay
billions of dollars their market cap
right there if you look at look at their
market cap right now
what's the market cap of spotify 36.4
billion dollars do you see it
did you see the market cap of spotify
36.4 billion dollars yes if you're
talking 45
what is a drop-off to go to 36 billion
dollars that's 70 billion dollar
valuation you talk about they lost
nearly 22 to 24 billion dollars in 12
months we're not talking a little bit of
money so imagine the conference calls
where investors are on and saying how
are you handling
joe rogan what are you going to do about
imagine a board board is sitting there
saying hey like i remember my board we
had a meeting it was a tough
conversation they had with me
what are you doing to get 100 to what
are you doing to get your agents to get
vaccinated it's a conversation i had
with me and my board meeting so i'm
sitting there i'm having to have a
conversation with them
they've had to have a conversation with
daniel saying what are we doing about
you're also you are also giving a great
lecture for your audience about why i am
a 501c3 non-profit organization which
protects the freedom of association
rights for donors to the first amendment
because we don't have this problem we
don't have to disclose our the supreme
court has protected our right they can't
boycott our donors because they don't
know their names
and this is the problem i'm going to go
back to my argument this is the problem
with
these
for-profit
news because joe rogan is technically a
man who's disseminating information and
news is that
they'll invariably fold you know and
that's why
i i i don't i
i've seen it
the first chapter in my book is called
suffering
because the amount of pain that this man
is gonna that ekka's gonna have to
endure to go through this
i mean i i think the only way forward is
philanthropic
non-profit sort of uh
the model to get information out there
where they can't boycott and target the
people that support you so as soon as
the uh the hundred million dollar
contracts happen uh we'll see what
happens we'll see what happens i think i
i don't think rogan's going anywhere i
think rogan's gonna be in demand for a
long time to come i don't think robin
rogan's gonna have a problem because the
the yesterday when he posted a video did
you guys see the commentary on what
people said to him do you guys did you
look at the commentary
so let me ask you a question if you go
to rogan's instagram post so check this
out go to his instagram post just tap it
in google instagram joe rogan i want to
show you a couple people that commented
that says who joe is so when you think
about the rock what do you think about
the rock type it right there click on
that what do you think the rock is left
right center where do you put the rock
politically i don't know center-ish well
he protected he defended uh what do you
call it uh
uh well keith doesn't see left right
center
exactly but you know he went out there
and he had the biting on a kamala
harrison but he didn't have trump on
right so he supported one side now while
you look at that i'll read it okay if
you can't find it i'll read it here
so when he posted this video here's a
commentary
uh it got
four million views okay million likes
okay
uh the here's what the rock said the
rock dwayne
johnson said in the comment section
he commented and he said something about
hey man you know
i obviously tulsi gabbard commented i'm
trying to find the rock's comments jewel
commented sure
but there is one from the rock man if
you can't find it i hope he didn't
delete it i mean this thing was up
yesterday uh and something about hey i
can't wait to come on one of these days
and be on the podcast it's crazy that it
hasn't been on yet yeah he said i'd love
to one of these okay there you go great
stuff here brother perfectly articulated
look forward to coming on one day and
breaking out the tequila with you okay
and got sixty thousand a comment got
sixty thousand likes so
he's protected joe is gonna be in demand
no matter where he goes you're saying
he's uncancelable i i don't know if i'm
gonna say he's uncancible i when i sat
down with joe
my suggestion to him was the only way
you can protect yourself 100 long term
is to do what consider opening up your
own thing for example if he and musk
teamed up together
imagine if him and musk teamed up
together to start something yeah right
yeah i agree with you that was that was
profound you have to be the chairman of
your own company
yeah you have to be the owner and
chairman to be to be a journalist yeah
even even to let's take that to the like
what you're doing to be a journalist
like that's a very astute point i i want
to comment on this
i didn't start out thinking i'm going to
create a business with 75 employees and
20 million dollar budget of course i've
never thought i'm going to do that i
said i need to tell this truth i need to
expose this thing and then along the way
i realized okay in order to not settle
the lawsuit i have to have the autonomy
the power to make that decision no one
would have ever allowed me to make these
decisions unless i was in control of
making those decisions so you're right i
think
i think he has to be the owner and the
controller and right now he's
i guess he's in contract with spotify is
that correct four years he's not on the
board of spotify right not no he's not
well that's the issue so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]